I am like that I with Tom like this
store I'm sorry crowd now it's our very
subtle very subtle gathering we found
here the Westfield State station hey do
you you piece looks super bulky this
isn't this was intimidating I thought it
would be a little lobby in front of the
local cinema I didn't realize we'd be in
the atrium surrounded by you know 6,000
screaming shoppers wondering what the
hell's going on okay all right now tom
yum yum screen for a while and now
you're wack co-director you'll directing
co-writing I'm sorry you don't do things
by balls do you well once you're that
you know if you're going to throw down
throw down babe if you're going to go to
training train for the long haul so we
started this we didn't know if it was
really going to pop but somewhere you
get to this you get to this place where
it's either go or no go and it was just
well it was just go and with within 15
minutes I was calling Julia Roberts on
the phone and see as you do
you directed this you directing yourself
I think I you know I think I think I
hosted a very good good movies new you
want to have everything to come in and
feel like they're doing good work that
they're appreciated and they can tell me
to do anything they want to that they
look forward to getting up at four
thirty five in the morning coming into
work I half of that was my job and the
rest of it was just making sure all the
all the marbles added up to a full bag
and she goes what was she give me mother
trouble not trouble no no but she's you
know she's got you she made sure that
your elegant said you know you know
you're actually delivering on the goods
that you sort of promised her on the
phone she has some ideas that are always
going to make it better and said he got
to be open to that I'm doing a film you
child school yourself from a bit of a
geek too quiet hate guy yeah but I hand
myself over to the taste of a good woman
so that's that is actually the way most
been do it they dressed like idiots and
Attila girl come alone assist here try
this on and I certainly see if they try
things on black goes a little better on
the fashion front I didn't realize the
same he's quite some of the kids well
I'm down with it I'm down with the guys
mowing their lawn on sound that's all
I'm downward come on student asked you
so very good time thank you for coming
what actions